everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess it can well let's talk about the
animation real quick because there are
so many different animation
Styles how were you able to basically
organize and and basically keep all of
these different universes uh these
worlds spinning
well um I'm glad it came off as
organized to you the bottom line is that
the the movie is grounded in miles and
his family and his relationship with
Gwen and the other spider people so it's
you know as long as we stay rooted in
that we're in business and the other
stuff is exciting and thrilling to see
in the movie theater and we're so proud
of how it got realized but the end of
the day it's your emotional engagement
with Miles that that that you know keeps
you involved and we wanted the each
world to have its own look and own feel
like it was animated by a different
artist and you're walking into a
different painting in each universe that
you visited and each one the style came
out of its origin so with Gwen we start
in Gwen's world and and that her world
was based on the on the comic book
covers uh of of her runs which have this
beautiful watercolor gouache feel has
the sort of drippy wet painting feel and
we thought it would be fun if if her
world reflected her the subjectivity of
her mood and her emotions uh and so it's
easy to know like okay I'm in Gwen's
world this is how it feels and you want
not to have its own distinct look but
then you want uh you know in Spider-Man
India's world to have its own look and
that was based on these individual
comics from India in the 70s and 80s
that had bright colors and sort of crazy
uh you know crazy color combos and sort
of very quick drawings with Loosely
registered uh colors and and and having
that be the inspiration for that and
having each world have its own sort of
story reason for existing uh makes it
easy to be like okay I where am I just
taking one look at the world I know what
Universe I'm in uh and so it was a great
opportunity to sort of show you know the
breadth of possibility and cinematically
in animation I'm so glad you brought up
the comics because I was like how I've
mentioned this I'm a comic book fan and
I was having a ball I saw Spider-Man
2099 I saw spider getting in there I saw
Ezra's spider-verse like and then I was
just blown away because I'm trying to
figure out how you figured out which
covers issues to use and then which of
the there's over 240 characters in this
film which how did you go about picking
which characters I just put them all in
uh no listen it all comes from you know
what is a great compliment to the main
storyline who could possibly be cooler
than miles oh wait there's Hobie Brown
you know we found someone and someone to
like you know it's kind of that thing
where like you leave home you know you
were like doing pretty well in high
school and you go off to college and
you're like oh my God I'm a scrub again
pop is another guy that's like he's like
you know maybe younger than Miles and
he's somehow like incredibly competent
and cool in his own way and like
incredibly self-assured right and he's
like he's unashamed of himself and it's
just fine finding ways to put miles on
his heels when he's already like the
coolest Spider-Man you've ever seen so
having miles move through this universe
similar to he did in the first one but
if the universe is so much bigger it was
really interesting also seeing his
animation style blend with the others
let's talk about uh the rogue's Gallery
a little bit let's talk about spot
because I thought the spot was a very
interesting choice as the villain or
main villain in this film how do you go
about choosing the baddies well you know
we you know the this movie went through
a big evolution and at one point it was
actually Avia Rod who said to us what
about the spot as a villain and we
thought the spot that's the dorkiest
villain he's like a looney
um maybe that's an idea right and we
realized uh later that it actually was
perfect you know not just because he has
these dimensional portals that fit into
the story but also the story of a
character that we discounted was like oh
it's been overlooked that's sort of
ridicule that's not considered like a
big deal Spider-Man villain like what if
the story of the movie was watching him
come into his own as a villain so it's a
coming-of-age story for miles but it's
also coming of age story for the villain
right and so it was a great sort of
counter like a parallel story to what
miles was going on he wanted to feel
seen and appreciated uh and and you know
and that's what spot wants but he just
takes a darker path and the idea that we
could take something that felt like a
silly joke of a villain and turn into
something really formidable that you
would be you know terrified of by the
end seemed like a really fun and
daunting Challenge and we love it when
something seems hard to do so uh so
that's okay everyone and you know both
of these guys want to be seen and
legitimized right and both mistakenly
seeking that from outside of themselves
and really only miles learns uh that you
know he has to get it from inside he
absolutely does and and I I think he
also finds a mentor in Hobie who you
mentioned earlier I just want to Circle
back to his animation again real quick
hobie's animation and his design look so
much different than a lot of the other
characters how did you come up with that
he's a punk you know spider Punk so we
were like well he should look like a
punk scene or like a punk poster right
which is using lots of Xerox technology
and like colored paper and appropriating
imagery from you know a magazine and
then there's never enough toner in the
copy machine so it always has kind of a
grayed out quality to it but it's the
idea of it is like it's found it's
discovered and nothing is thrown away
the reason like punks look like that is
it's like a statement about like you
think I'm trash but I think I'm hot like
it was so important for him to and pop
you succeeded because everybody I'm
telling you everybody's gonna want like
this character
right but he's making a political
statement about you know what is
legitimate and what isn't and what's so
funny is that like this is like an
organization that sort of
trying to make Conformity out of a group
that's the most non-conformist grouper
everybody's different animated in a
different style they look completely
different they all come from their own
worlds that have their own perspective
and so he was a perfect Counterpoint to
sort of what Miguel is trying to do
right Miguel is saying like there's a
certain way that things have to happen
and the punk ethos is like no there
isn't I don't even have to learn to play
this instrument I can still get up and
perform right we're really lucky to be
able to use that character super blessed
to have Daniel kaluya who is like the
essence of punk as a human being who's
from Camden town of all places so yeah
it was we were just we we it was a
thrill to work on that character with
him talk me through way you knew this
was going to be a Trilogy because I feel
like you know with the first movie was
so groundbreaking change the game in
terms of Animation gave gave everybody
the miles that they wanted to see on
screen how did you know how far you
wanted to take this film
well for a while we had been trying to
jam two movies into one like we had so
much we wanted to tell in the next story
and we realized the movie was telling us
that what became this film was its own
film and the the stuff after that was
felt like another another story because
in this one you know it has a beginning
middle and end and Miles starts in one
place and he ends in another one Gwen
start going and had her relationship
with with uh with her bandmates and with
her father starting one place and then
in another you know Peter starts in one
place and ends another everybody has an
arc uh and then the plot has some things
that uh uh are unfinished and so we
realized oh this isn't like a mega big
uh gargantuan movie this is a movie it's
the second movie in a Trilogy
um and that's when we realized uh uh
what we had to do and uh and thankfully
everybody that went along with it every
amazing
big test movie who was your dream
voiceover get for across the
spider-verse I mean where do you start
like you know every time we were in the
recording booth with someone we were
just in awe you know from Oscar Isaac to
Issa Ray who's like just good at
everything and also wonderful it really
is and she's also like tall she's like
could you just like be like average at
something please well that's what you
feel that way about the whole cast I
mean even the even the people who were
in the first movie you know like you
know Haley also is an amazing actor an
incredible singer she stars in these
these really like deeply profound indie
films and big Blockbusters she can do it
all everyone in the academy he's Hawkeye
yeah yeah I mean everybody in the past
has so much range that you're like you
can work with them as partners in
developing the character and developing
the voice and thinking about what the
about the film and so you're not just
having people come in and just say the
lines you're work shopping a scene right
like when Shea Wiggum and Gwen have
their scenes together like that's
something that we talked about like
every few months we would bring them in
and we'd redo the scene and add new
things and they brought stuff from their
lives into it like you're workshopping
it same thing you know Jason Schwartzman
who like when we pitched him the
character of spots he was like oh I love
the fact that he's full of holes that's
so important to me and every like
session with Jason we had to like extend
right because the first hour is just
like talking about everything right and
the poor editors you know they had so
much material to go right yeah he would
just like keep trying and sort of
improvising different ideas and versions
and variations of takes and and go down
these roads and and then we'd be like
okay here's take uh J take K take L take
Z take z a c b they're like oh my God oh
my God it sounds like the majority of
the creative process especially on this
film was happening in the record Booth
it wasn't happening in you know it seems
like the writing was the jumping off
point and most of the creative was
happening with the talent but you it
happens everywhere I mean specific to
the writing like the writing never stops
right it's like it's not like you you
write a screenplay thank you very much
goodbye it's like you're the you know
the writing is essential to every single
step of this process
um and you're working with a thousand
crew members each one has smart things
to add and you the great thing about
animation is that you get to you put it
up with storyboards animatics and you
get to see an early version of it and
see if it's if it's working or not and
and you know the artists get to say like
well what if we did this and what if we
tried this and you get to go back and
and work it and rework it and then when
the actors come in you've got another
chance to rework it and then the
animators come and go like actually it
would be more cool if we did this and
everybody's building on it as long as
it's helping tell the story more clearly
and effectively and making it more
engaging it's uh it just makes it a much
richer richer experience but it's a
really uh collaborative process you just
mentioned a thousand and I had a note
about that there's over a thousand
people working on this film which is
reportedly the largest group of any
animated film ever that is correct
that's not daunting is it
no it's very it's a big responsibility
and um you know luckily we had you know
all of those individuals brought
something of themselves to the movie
that's the goal that we're not like
taking the average of everybody's ideas
but rather we're amplifying the
individuality of all of the artists yeah
I mean we had such an ambitious film it
takes a lot of people to make it I mean
we had three directors on this film you
know and each one brought a specialty
area that they were like an expert in
and one of the best people in the world
at and so everybody was able to sort of
be like a jazz band where everyone gets
to do a solo but they all get to play
together and we're a basketball team
where it's like you know like there's no
look passes right as somebody like has
is in their back bag and then like part
of it is like they have to pass to
somebody in the corner who has to hit
the shot like there's not any single
um person that can do this movie on
their own right and it's our job to sort
of like Express the goal that we should
all be heading towards and then
everybody else gets to participate in
that and go like well what if we did
this wouldn't that make this more
interesting and everyone Builds on each
other and that's how you get something
that is this rich and deep and like
re-watchable uh because it's not just
you know one person's whim it's a
thousand people's really thoughtful
ideas yeah it was pulled off so
excellently
um getting to last couple questions how
will the next film Beyond the spider
verse differentiate itself from across
the spider verse visually I know you
can't tell me about the plot but like
visually are you looking to push the
boundaries of Animation again I would
say that's the brand so we would be we
don't have a choice
um and we've got some great ideas for um
where the movie goes to next and uh some
opportunities to explore some of the
visual ideas in this movie even
um more richly right I think you know
the fun thing about this is that every
world you go to is a bespoke world and
each World feels like its own animation
style so we're gonna visit a bunch of
new places in the third film and each
one is going to have a look that you've
never seen before and and the the goal
of these films is to make you to
surprise and delight and to make you go
I have never seen anything like this in
my entire life I can't I I have to see
it again to really fully process what I
just saw uh and
um and so you know that's our goal for
the third one as well now you two are
also working on the Spider-Man Noir show
is there anything from this movie that
we're gonna like is that that we're
pulling into that show also where did a
thousand people also are gonna work on
that show like that that shows a live
action show so it's a it's a different
process obviously and it is you know
it's it's on hold right now because of
the writer strike but it was uh
progressing along really well as does
the silk show uh also that's you know uh
being worked on as well and they're both
really exciting and really different
from each other but you know the idea
that there is a Multiverse out there in
each world uh is telling its own story
in its own way is sort of the you know
the the backbone of that but it's
allowing people to sort of tell their
version of a story
um and you know Angela with silk has
really like got a really strong vision
of what that would look like in Oren uh
with with Spider-Man Noir has a really
really great uh vision for how that how
how the tone and Vibe of that should be
and they're really really smart and
they're doing an amazing job do you have
ideas for stories Beyond these two
sequels like if you had a character that
you could pull out of this movie and
make make another show about them if
they gave you a gazillion dollars
which character would that be I mean
there's the possibilities are Limitless
um we're big fans of uh the Western
genre so uh I wouldn't mind working with
uh web Slinger and Widow one more time
but in reality like we're so these
things are so ambitious and we're just
finishing this Trilogy is exhausting and
so it's a better question in the future
after we've had a nice long nap and we
uh are ready to to dig into something
new uh but we've you know we've still
got our work ahead of us that's for sure